nouveau numéro de reporter sur france 24
le dynamisme démographique de l'afrique
un impact considérable sur les villes
qui ne cesse de croître il en va ainsi
de la capitale du rwanda où nous allons
nous rendre aujourd'hui la population de
tigali va doubler d'ici 2050 là-bas dans
une des zones déjà les plus densément
peuplés au monde les autorités tentent
de canaliser et d'organiser cette
croissance sur le plan urbanistique mais
aussi économique avec nous pour en
parler simon wohlfarth qui est
correspondant de france 24 au rwanda
simon le ronde a de grandes ambitions
sur le continent et kigali en sera la
vitrine c'est le plan du président
kagame et c'est ce que nous allons
découvrir dans votre reportage
oui ce n'est pas l'envergure du rwanda
qui va en limiter les ambitions cet état
de la taille de la bretagne est
évidemment connu pour avoir été le
théâtre du dernier génocide du xxème
siècle le génocide des tutsis en 94
c'est un pays qui s'est reconstruit de
manière fulgurante et qui est
aujourd'hui un partenaire privilégié des
bailleurs mais ce développement est
clair se fait souvent au prix d'une
répression féroce contre toute
opposition
lorsque l'on parcourt le rwanda ce qui
impressionne c'est que non seulement le
pays s'est relevé mais il se développe à
grande vitesse et d'ici à 30 ans sa
population va presque doubler il n'y a
alors pas une seule parcelle au rwanda
qui ne soit déjà occupé exploiter il est
en somme des gens partout dans le pays
et cette croissance démographique va
poser un certain nombre de défis pour la
société rwandaise autant en termes de
logement d'emploi que d'impact
environnemental et c'est ce qu'on va
découvrir dans votre reportage simon
vous retrouve juste après rwanda le défi
de la surpopulation reportage tourné
avec bastien renouil pour france 24
[Musique]
françois vécu dans ce quartier à flanc
de colline durant près de quatre
décennies
mais il y a deux ans sa famille a dû
quitter sa maison sur ordre des
autorités
[Musique]
on m
elle risquait de s'effondrer en cas de
glissement de terrain durant la saison
des pluies
[Musique]
nous notre parcelle arriver jusqu'ici
ici il y avait une maison que j'avais
mis en location au gré du développement
de la capitale les constructions sont
venues des figures et les collines et
fragiliser la terre aujourd'hui ce
quartier voué à la destruction
fini les habitations informel kigali
doit être réinventé le projet
d'urbanisme 2050 prévoit une ville
moderne est organisée au risque
d'exclure les plus pauvres à l'époque de
l'ancien maire ils sont venus marquer ma
maison pour signifier qu'elle devait
être détruite comme toutes les maisons
autour nous ont promis une compensation
puis un jour on m'a donné l'ordre de
déménager de détruire moi même ma maison
ses voisins attendent toujours de
recevoir l'ordre final d'évacuation
[Musique]
que
la population en croissance constante
est un enjeu de taille pour les
autorités
[Musique]
et qu'il ya loi aujourd'hui un million
trois cent mille devrait être trois fois
plus nombreux dans trente ans
la capitale veut désormais logés ces
nouveaux habitants dans des immeubles
après son éviction françois reçu
gratuitement un appartement dans ce
quartier flambant neuf
ce jour là le vice-maire bien sonder la
satisfaction des déplacés
j'habitais dans le district de gasabo
gasabo dans le quartier de tchimou roura
c'est ça
nous sommes heureux car les habitants
considèrent que nous les avons sauvées
en les faisant déménager dans un endroit
très confortable oui si on compte des
raves nous souhaiterions avoir plus
d'argent pour construire des
appartements
pour plus de familles
au cours des trois prochaines décennies
la ville va changer de visage
neuf cent mille logements seront
nécessaires
le nombre de gens qui vivaient sur plus
de 10 hectares
nous arrivons à les loger
sur moins de 3,5 hectares
nous construisons plus haut comme vous
le voyez
kigali sept ans avec ses résidences
situées en périphérie de la ville
mais pour ceux qui vivent il n'est pas
toujours facile de retrouver une
activité professionnelle
avant qu est ce que tu faisais comme je
suis vieux je m'occupais de mes chèvres
et ici qu'est ce que tu fais ici c'est
impossible de travailler il n'y a pas de
place pour l'élevage ni pour un potager
nous sommes plus en sécurité la maison
n'est jamais envahi par l'eau il n'ya
pas non plus de colline à escalader mais
financièrement nous n'avons plus aucune
source de revenus l'appartement de
françois est un trois pièces
si le vieil homme est satisfait par la
qualité de la construction le logement
est exigu pour la famille de 5 in salah
voici le salon
c'est la pièce de séjour et la salle à
manger en même temps
il ne peut pas contenir plus que ces
chaises et cette table finale tient ici
c'est la chambre des parents il ya le
lier leurs habits
et cette chambre c'est pour nous les
enfants
j'ai pu voir la ville se développer au
cours des années
nous vivions avant nous n'avions pas
d'électricité pas d'accès à la route
comme aujourd'hui c'est mieux
mais malgré ça l'essentiel nous manque
je n'ai pas de quoi acheter des habits à
mes enfants ou même de la nourriture
nous sommes très malheureux donc on
apprend
la nourriture est le deuxième enjeu de
cette explosion démographique
il faut produire un maximum de produits
alimentaires
75% des rondes et vivent de
l'agriculture
la moindre parcelle est exploité souvent
jusqu'à l'extrême fragilisant la terre
alors comme à kigali quand la pluie
vient dans les campagnes les foyers les
plus précaires sont en danger
la vie de florence et ses trois enfants
est rythmée par les glissements de
terrain
je suis en train de déménager parce que
j'ai peur des eaux qui ruissellent
et qui emporte la terre
chaque fois pendant la saison des pluies
je suis obligé d'en porter mes affaires
et de quitter temporairement ma maison
pour m'abriter en sécurité
a guide to be des dizaines de personnes
meurent chaque année à cause des
éboulements au
début il n'y avait qu'une petite rigole
d'eau qui passait par là ça s'est
agrandi le petit appétit
j'avais une grande maison avant jusqu'à
ce que la talent porte et là ce trou
béant nous avons dû reconstruire par ici
pour permettre aux agriculteurs de
récolter toujours plus tout en étant
sécurité les autorités ont lancé un plan
pharaonique de restructuration du
district le projet green guy chumby un
employé du fonds roindefo environnement
vient faire un état des lieux de la
situation due aux accidents fait cette
crevasse a été identifiée comme l'une
des plus dangereuses ou 13 cause ici il
y a beaucoup d'érosion elles causent
beaucoup de dégâts en aval en tant que
membre du projet green guy koubbi nous
essayons de réhabiliter ces endroits et
de les protéger
afin de réduire les dégâts causés dans
les champs et sur les propriétés de la
communauté
les habitants les plus exposés à ces
risques comme florence ont l'espoir de
voir leur vie changer
à quelques kilomètres de là au sommet
d'une colline
le projet green guy chumby construit un
village modèle écologique plus
résistants aux effets du changement
climatique pour reloger les déplacer
des césar d c'est l'une des maisons qui
est en cours de construction dans le
cadre du village vert
c'est une maison pour une famille
pour l'instant le village sortent à
peine de terre
à terme il pourra accueillir cinquante
familles
ce modèle devrait être répliquée dans
tout le rwanda ça
c'est le village du futur c'est le
modèle de village qui sera adoptée dans
chaque district c'est respectueux de
l'environnement il y aura un système de
collecte de l'eau de collecte des eaux
de pluie qui était un des piliers du
village vers
plus de deux ans après le début des
travaux sur l'ensemble du district guide
to be est un grand chantier à ciel
ouvert
pour augmenter la productivité en bois
lutter contre l'érosion des sols des
colonnes de femmes plantes des
eucalyptus par milliers
ici tout le paysage est transformée sur
les collines l'agriculture intensive se
fait désormais en terrasse félix vient
rendre visite à cette fermière qui a
adopté la pratique
quand je travaillais sur la terre en
pente les semences les plantes était
balayé par les pluies et tous se
retrouver au fond de la vallée
la récolte était mauvaise
aujourd'hui avec les terrasses il y a
plus de rendement qu avant
d accord avec ce type d'aménagement les
récoltes sont trois fois plus
importantes qu'avant défaut
une fois que nous consolidons la terre
comme ceux ci nous conseillons aux
communautés de pratique et de la
monoculture saisonnière
grâce à ses solutions la nourriture ne
devrait plus être un problème
mais subsiste un ultime défi l'emploi
il n'y aura bientôt plus assez de terres
pour fournir du travail à tous le
gouvernement mise donc sur le marché des
services comme le tourisme
et cela paie
ces dix dernières années le pib par
habitant a progressé de 5% par an
dans la capitale des dizaines d'hôtels
ont ouvert leurs portes et attire de
plus en plus de jeunes travailleurs
jean rémy a rejoint l'école de
management va-t-elle il y a deux ans
[Musique]
in disponible dans cette formation
l'objectif principal est d'apprendre
tout ce qu'il ya à savoir sur le service
dans un restaurant comme ça si un jour
je suis responsable d'un établissement
je pourrais diriger mes employés je
saurai comment les encadrer
cette école française a ouvert une
antenne au rwanda en 2018 pour améliorer
les qualifications dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie
son objectif répondre aux attentes des
plus grands établissements de kigali et
éviter qu'ils recrutent à l'étranger
l'industrie hôtelière dans ce pays est
en pleine croissance elle monte elle est
en plein essor nous devons il sait ce
secteur un autre niveau
après les cours pas le temps de se
reposer
direction le marriott pour son stage en
entreprise ici séjourne hommes
d'affaires et riches touristes
alors lorsqu'il doit réaliser les
cocktails les plus raffinés l'erreur
n'est pas permise
la plupart des clients internationaux
viennent ici avec des attentes ils ont
déjà été dans d'autres hôtels cinq
étoiles auparavant donc quand ils
viennent ici on ne peut pas les décevoir
l'étudiant ne compte pas ses heures il
sait qu'il doit en passer par là pour
profiter du dynamisme économique de son
pays
avec l'obtention de mon diplôme en
management pour va-t-elle
et avec les compétences que j'ai acquise
lors de mon stage en entreprise
je suis sûr de trouver un emploi qui me
convient
après son service jean rémy rejoint
l'une de ses collègues stagiaires
l'occasion de discuter des difficultés
du quotidien
comme eux de plus en plus de jeunes
rwandais tentent leur chance dans ce
domaine
c'est délicat
c'est un secteur vraiment compétitif
avant nous n'avions qu'une seule
l'université pour cette industrie et
maintenant il y en a plus de 5 cela
signifie qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
entrent sur le marché du travail ça crée
une énorme concurrence
quand vous travaillez
que vous faites de votre mieux que vous
utilisez vos compétences et vos
connaissances
si l'employeur vois que vous en faites
plus que les autres il vous donnera un
emploi
ils sont prêts à tout pour obtenir un
travail au terme de leurs études
alors pour parvenir à son objectif de
devenir un pays à revenu intermédiaire
d'ici à 2035 grâce notamment à son
économie de services leur honda mise
désormais sur la génération de jean rémy
[Musique]
et avec nous à kigali simon wohlfarth
dans votre reportage simon vous dites
que le rwanda veut devenir un pays à
revenu intermédiaire comment ont-ils
atteindre cet objectif
le rwanda c'est un petit état enclavé
d'afrique centrale et dont la grande
majorité de la population dépend encore
aujourd'hui de l'agriculture pour vivre
alors pour se développer les autorités
ont tenté de passer d'une économie
principalement agricoles à une économie
de services et ça en très peu de temps
en s'affichant comme une destination
sûre et dynamique pour toutes sortes
d'entreprises le tourisme de conférences
c-17 ainsi beaucoup développée ici ces
dernières années depuis 2010 est la
capitale rwandaise a accueilli des
centaines d'événements et le secteur
aurait rapporté à l'économie du pays des
centaines de millions de dollars il ya
trois ans kigali a même été considérée
comme la deuxième meilleure ville du
continent africain pour l'organisation
des conférences
ce dynamisme a permis au rwanda de
dégager une croissance économique assez
impressionnante et en fait autour de 10%
par an mais cette croissance s'est faite
au prix de beaucoup d'investissements
d'argent public et d'emprunts à
l'étranger quitte à faire exploser le
niveau de la dette du rwanda passée de
19% à 56 % du pib en presque dix ans
alors relever le défi l'augmentation de
population passe donc par d'importants
besoins financiers les autorités
continuent de chercher des investisseurs
à l'étranger je vous propose alors
d'écouter le vice-maire de kigali à ce
sujet tous mt fait voter d'ici à 2050 et
mémé d'aurora aider nous aurons besoin
de fournir 27 mille logements par an à
notre population
mais on n'y est pas du tout
nous encourageons les gens et programmes
à venir investir dans des logements
abordables et sociaux zynga
nous attirons plus d'investisseurs pour
s'assurer que le nombre d'habitations
que nous fournissons par an augmente pas
une crise merci beaucoup simon wohlfarth
à kigali pour france 24 c'est la fin de
ce magazine merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur françois
[Musique]